nato allies are in summit mode posing
for pictures yet behind the hugs and the
handshakes they're hardening their
defenses against russia in the biggest
overhaul since the cold war but will it
be enough to stop the very hot war in
ukraine from spreading
the head of the alliance certainly hopes
so
president putin's war against ukraine
has shattered peace in europe
and has created the biggest security
crisis in europe since the second world
war
it's prompted allies like u.s president
joe biden and britain's boris johnson to
pledge more forces to defend nato by
land sea air cyber space and even outer
space
they're helping ukraine too
it's not a member of the alliance but
its wartime president addressed the
summit calling for more weapons
prosperity
nato allies bolstered their defenses
following russia's first invasion of
ukraine in 2014 but it wasn't enough
this time round the response feels
different more credible yet it's a huge
test of resolve and security across the
whole of europe is at stake
and then there's the other big challenge
china
but not all allies agree on the scale of
the problem
we don't look at china as a threat we do
believe that if there's a pragmatic and
respect based cooperation between the
western world and the china we can take
a lot of benefits
others inside this alliance will beg to
differ
debra haynes sky news madrid